esta joven guatemalteca dice que tejer
estas pulseras le permite escapar de sus
pensamientos cuando tenía 13 años Fue
violada cinco veces por el pastor de su
pueblo después de meses de acoso sexual
el insomnio las ganas de no comer todas
las noches me ponía a llorar y decía que
por qué a mí Dios estuvo ahí conmigo
al que no quedara embarazada en el país
centroamericano se reportan cada día 23
abusos sexuales a niñas y adolescentes y
las víctimas no encuentran en Guatemala
un sistema de Justicia cooperativo dos
años después de los hechos la
sobreviviente cuenta un proceso lento y
desgastante su agresor fue condenado a
26 años de cárcel pero todavía sigue
libre
no no me parece un proceso fácil porque
el psicólogo me preguntaba cosas que
ella no quería recordar me hicieron
quitarme la ropa me investigaron
ante este drama que viven miles de niñas
en el país la asociación asogen les
brinda apoyo legal para presentar las
denuncias así como talleres de
empoderamiento económico vienen de zonas
muy vulnerables es decir que son de
escasos recursos personas analfabetas
que no tienen ningún grado de Educación
normalmente son personas que tienen una
dependencia económica en mayor parte de
su agresor esa violencia se refleja en
otras cifras en 2022 según el
observatorio en salud sexual y
reproductiva se registraron más de
67.000 embarazos de niñas entre 10 y 19
años para frenar esa violencia su gente
necesario reforzar las políticas para la
prevención de embarazos sin embargo en
Guatemala se impulsó el año pasado una
iniciativa de ley que intentaba prohibir
la educación sexual en las escuelas